welcome back to the iced coffee hour my
name is ryan pineda and the podcast has
made
336 thousand dollars wow great guess
it's 202
112
close very close thank you so much for
making it on man yeah we appreciate you
back it's been a while yeah i know we
got the real estate expert here yeah
buying up a lot of real estate this year
you know i think i said it the last two
iced coffee hours that everyone needs to
keep buying and they would have did
pretty good how much have you bought
this year so far ah this year i think
we've been buying around 10 a month so
we're buying a lot and that's just slips
that's all in las vegas as well yeah
those are flips and then obviously we're
buying the apartments now which we'll
talk about so it's going good wow
well before we go into the state of the
real estate market what you're doing
what you're buying and if there are any
good deals out there we i got to ask you
every single shot uh we set up the
camera here you look chiseled yeah how
do you how do you do this what's your
secret man um
do you do i have done like botox or
anything like that or do you just like
what's the secret no dude you know it's
funny people ask me like do you have um
fake teeth do you do botox and like do
you do the hair restoration and i'm like
dude i've haven't done any of that the
only thing i've ever done is i have two
fake teeth right here and now people
will know about it but they're kind of
discolored because they're they're fake
and they can't be colored but um
no no botox or anything why why two
teeth on the side uh when i was younger
i had braces and all that stuff and then
when they removed them like these two
teeth were like really tiny just super
small and so if they had to fill them in
they put like the fake
caps on them or something and then
eventually as i got older they're like
you can do veneers now and so yeah two
fake veneers just because they were
small teeth do you get like 11 hours of
sleep every night because you have no
bags no wrinkles it you just look
pristine well you know i don't edit my
own videos i think editing is what kills
all these creators dude
really editing is a lot of work man you
guys are up late that's true i but no i
i don't know i go to bed at like 11 wake
up at 5 30.
do you wear sunscreen moisturizer
how can we emulate trying to find them
like
i know i graham it's just dude i tell
people this all the time it's just being
asian dude asians look younger and um
they have better skin which is what it
is
i've been moisturizing now for like
three months every single day morning
and night i've been putting on the
moisturizer on my face to help with
wrinkles yeah i like that um cerave
shout out to them they've got like a
moisturizing cream so i like that
that keeps it nice
i'll try it and
you uh you walked in here
wait check oh you wanna try it so you
walked in
i see myself in in the in the podcast i
know me too man i look terrible i'm 23.
i look like i'm 45.
man anyway so this watch you walk in
rocking this watch it's uh ap
royal oak and it's massive yeah so sure
yep so i bought this oh wait wait alex
is supposed to guess how much you bought
that for me oh okay alex
yeah so uh guys my camera is out here
but uh my guess is that that watch costs
approximately uh 17 500
alex i'm guessing i'm guessing 85 no
my guess is uh
35 because you got a deal and you could
buy it at msrp
i wish so i bought this i think i did a
youtube video maybe
seven eight months ago um i've been
looking for this specific watch for over
a year i think i even showed you it
graham like you were the first person
back in 2020 to be like you should treat
yourself with a watch i was like i'm
never going to buy a watch i don't need
them and you're like no it's a good
investment it's a way to hold your money
and stuff i was like all right i'm going
to buy a watch
and so it sounds like something i would
say jack's wearing his submariner i i
had to talk him into buying this yeah
yeah
it's like almost double what what jack
got it for us yep so that's the other
watch i have is the exact same one as
jack so i go to this place called happy
jeweler um and he does a lot of athletes
and stuff like that out in california
and he just so happened to get this
watch in stock and i text him for months
i was like if you ever see this exact
watch let me know i love black and blue
and um he says i got it in stock you
know i'm going to get you but it's above
msrp and at the time you know msrp on
these was like 35 000
and if you went on ebay or something
they were selling for 50 to 55 000. and
so i just started thinking about i'm
like ah man if i'm ever going to buy a
watch i'm not going to get an msrp they
won't even sell it to me ap won't sell
you a watch like this and so i said okay
like what can we do and he's like i'm
actually going to give it to you below
cost of what i have it at he's like just
because i know you're going to make
content it's going to help out i want to
build a relationship with you you're
going to refer me a bunch of clients
which i have you know now i'm talking
about it on this podcast right
um so i ended up getting it from him for
like 42 thousand
um
and i was looking at it on ebay the
other day and i think it was like worth
60 to 70 now so it's crazy yeah the
watch market is ridiculous right now it
makes no sense to me yeah at all so i
think eventually rolex prices are
beginning to come down believe it or not
they're finally gotten to that point
where people are starting to realize
maybe it's not worth triple over i mean
it's still ridiculously expensive but
it's come down a little bit yeah i mean
dude i mean real estate's one thing that
that's gone crazy but the luxury cars
and watches and all this stuff you're
like i don't get it but
like my buddy flipped a lambo for like
50k the other day i'm like what's going
on here he drove it for six months
so what crazy times what compels you to
spend 45 000 on a watch
um graham graham told me to do
it good reason to do that yeah and i was
i was right yeah he was right yeah yeah
you guys can go back to that first
episode he was like buy it i was like
dude if like the cheapest millionaire
ever tells me to buy a luxury watch then
i have no excuse so um i don't know dude
i just
i've never bought like a luxury item
like this so i wanted to do it have you
found any value outside of like the the
monetary value of the watch like for
example like marketing and stuff like
that networking um so actually that
youtube video i did um it did really
well for me anyways but um i did a bunch
of tick tocks and reels and stuff from
that video we cut it up it was actually
my highest performing tick tock ever it
got 9 million views wow so
i mean now where it probably led to
something that got me more than forty
five thousand wow that's incredible
let's talk about how you got your start
for people that are not familiar with
you started in baseball could you tell
us about that and how you transition
that to working as a real estate agent
to then investing in real estate yeah so
growing up i never wanted to get into
real estate um i wanted to just play pro
baseball that was it just played little
league then you know high school got
division one scholarship became an
all-american then you know in 2010 i got
drafted by the oakland a's so
that was me like living my dream doing
what i wanted to do but um in the minor
leagues you make 1200 bucks a month
people don't really know that but you're
like scraping by for six months that's
all you're making you saw you can go get
another job and so
in the off seasons i had to
go work and make money somehow and so at
that time i was like well i can do this
realtor thing because
i i don't need to like go get a job and
then nobody's gonna hire me because i'm
gonna go leave six months from now so i
just became a realtor and i didn't
realize like that was the hardest time
ever to be a realtor because
prices were so cheap that even if you
sold something you didn't make much
um people were dealing with foreclosures
and bankruptcies and all this stuff so
nobody could buy and there was so much
inventory on the market that it just was
really hard to sell something because
people were like oh well i can go buy
eight million other things like why buy
this one the market's gonna keep going
down i can get a deal
and um it was a tough time and i i sold
some homes definitely wasn't that
successful at it um and after a couple
years i just kind of gave it up i was
like dude this is not for me
um i'm gonna go figure other stuff out
and so i started doing other side
hustles i was a substitute teacher for a
little bit
and then i started doing what's now kind
of famous with couch flipping
um you know it's just this thing i just
was like man i bet you i could go flip
this couch and make some good money and
it was right like i started making you
know eight thousand a month at my best
levels um flipping couches i was like
this is great
but eventually i got burnt out by that
too because that wasn't really
fulfilling and we kind of hit the cap of
buying every couch in las vegas
and i said dude what am i going to do
well in 2015
my wife and i are on our one-year
anniversary
we had saved up ten thousand dollars
from couchslipping and stuff and um
eventually i was just like praying one
day i'm like god what do you want me to
do with my life is it like baseball is
it you know couch flipping
i don't think it's real estate i suck at
that
um
and i just remember him showing me like
this commercial for flipping houses it
was like one of those scammy commercials
uh you know you could flip houses today
with no money no credit all this stuff
and i've been a realtor for five years
and i'm like i would have heard about
this by now there's no way that you can
do this and that's a scam well it led me
down the path of finding bigger pockets
which kind of influenced me and i was
like oh there is ways to do this you
could wholesale you could
raise private money you could get hard
money loans and so
um i ended up
going and finding my first deal after
that i got a hard money loan i maxed out
all my credit cards to
fund the down payment on that hard money
loan
and
thankfully
it worked out
i'm curious how do they do oh you maxing
out credit lines as a down payment yeah
are you just doing a cash out of that
like uh like taking out the the cash
from the credit cards and paying that
like high fee how are you doing that
yeah so
what happened was
i actually got credit lines for me and
my wife so we signed up for those zero
percent credit cards you know and it was
like 18 months zero percent and they had
like these balance transfers where they
would send you a check and so
we ended up doing the balance transfer
for a check
and um that's how i got 50 grand wow
than that
50 grand just from credit cards alone
yeah yep
and like hard money lenders people
people don't realize this they're not
like normal conventional or fha lenders
where they're looking at your debt to
income ratios and all that stuff like
all they really care about is the deal
itself and like do you have the down
payment and so if you got a good enough
deal they'll fund it and so that's what
happened like um i got a good deal and
he's like all right you need this amount
of money to fund it like you gonna do it
i was like yeah and so i got the money
maxed out the cards and was off to the
races but first i want to thank our
sponsor upstart graham i just bought a
premium subscription to every single
dating app and i don't have any matches
now and now i have a ton of high
interest credit card debt i don't know
what to do just calm down you could use
upstart upstart offers personal loans
that could help pay down high interest
credit card debt all online with simple
and easy to understand payment terms
once you get your loan upstart lets you
pay it back in one fixed monthly payment
with a clear payoff date upstart has
already helped 1.8 million people pay
off credit cards consolidate high
interest debt or fund personal expenses
bad credit
don't worry upstart knows you're more
than just a credit score and looks at
other factors like income employment and
other information provided in your loan
application to find you a smarter rate
for your loan you could check your rate
in minutes for loans between one
thousand to fifty thousand dollars
without impacting your credit score you
could even receive funds as fast as one
business day after accepting your loan
so don't wait and check your rate today
when you go to upstart.com iced coffee
that's upstart.com iced coffee down
below in the description so they know we
sent you once again upstart.com slash
iced coffee thank you so much upstart
and back to the backpack
podcast did you ever pay interest on
those credit cards or like what about
the the rates on the hard money loan as
well i'm wondering just like the actual
finances of this deal itself yeah so i
mean the hard money rates were 12
and four points so
very expensive today but back then you
know eight years ago going to seven
eight years ago wasn't i was like
whatever dude it's the cost of doing
business like i don't care um
so i did that i mean and the credit card
was zero percent for eighteen months so
it wasn't i had to pay you ended up yeah
i had to pay a fee of like three percent
to borrow the money but that was nothing
once again a cost of doing business how
much you making that first deal
that first deal made 25 grand profit
after you pay after the hard money
lender oh wow yeah so
from there i was like man this is this
is it this is the way to go and so i did
um five deals that first year then 20
the next year 50 the year after that and
then 150 um in year four and then i've
been doing a hundred ever since and
you know a bunch of businesses
spread off from that and you know now
we're doing the apartments and education
and everything else and in order to flip
houses that successfully you have to
have a lot of knowledge and i always
wonder because like i know a decent
amount about real estate and how you can
add value and stuff like that but it
seems like i'm surrounded by people that
just have like so much knowledge on that
type of stuff where did you learn that
stuff i actually did starting out was i
just was on bigger pockets i was
listening to a podcast like three times
a day while i was delivering couches i
was literally just learning the game
non-stop and so i remember i watched
every bigger pockets episode um for
probably the first 150 episodes i just
binged them
and that gave me the foundation of like
okay i get this and it also like gave me
confidence to hear all these other
people's stories who you know were in
the same boat i was in i was like oh if
these guys could do it i can do it
and so
you know i learned a lot doing that um i
started attending local meetups i
started you know networking with these
other guys and you know truthfully i
didn't do it the way that i would do it
now i just kind of like
winged it and just trial by error but
now i mean there's so many resources
with youtube with coaching programs with
like so many more transparent ways
versus back then you know eight years
ago nothing was like transparent it was
like you have to go to the free event
and then be up sold and then be up sold
and like then you'll learn the
information but now on youtube dude i
mean you can go watch my stuff you can
go watch other people's stuff and i'm
like here's how you do it boom boom boom
boom boom and you know anyone could
really get started today with no
information or i mean i guess no like
connections in the space youtube and
podcast can teach you but
um there's definitely a lot more you'll
speed up your time frame being with a
mentor and like
a program that can push you through
mm-hmm who cuts your hair dude i get a
haircut every monday is serious how much
does it cost
yes
80 bucks 80 bucks what do you think i
don't think
see the thing is it looks expensive it
can't be it can't be eight bucks is
pretty dang expensive
but like
uh
i see i think you have someone probably
coming to you you're not going in like
so my guess is probably 120 bucks yeah
so graham graham guest right i um i used
to go to the barber shop yeah you know
i'm like and honestly the typical
haircut is like 30 bucks and then you
tip them and you know i'd be usually at
like 50 bucks i'm like thanks dude um
and then i was like one day dude
this is wasting so much time having to
always come to the barber shop every
week like can you come to my house i was
like i'll pay you double he's like all
right so it's just a hundred bucks every
monday wow a hundred dollars worth four
hundred dollars a month on haircuts has
your wife not just said hey ryan we
gotta sit down we gotta talk about this
seriously would this not create like
arguments in the house because i just
would
how why
who's gonna argue what's the reason for
arguing yeah what are we arguing about
it's a hundred dollars a week for a you
don't need a haircut every week you do
when it's your signature
what difference does a week make
it does is it actually it's not as
crispy as you're seeing it today you'll
be like yeah he's got good hair but now
you're like dude how is it so crisp
you're talking about it right now
yeah i mean it's true but it's like the
line but see you could have the line for
more than just no you can't it would
grow in and i'd have to like maintain it
myself which is how did you pick that
haircut that's what like my hair
naturally does like my hair naturally
like goes up like i don't blow dry it i
don't do anything crazy like yeah i put
gel in it but um that's it
have you made a video my hair routine no
i need to that would honestly it would
blow up my hair routine and you just
show like you just got out of the shower
you know and you just like comb your
hair back put the gel in what kind of
gel you use something like that would be
how often you get a haircut that would
do really well yeah i should do it i
think though it pissed a lot of people
off because um people talk about my hair
all the time like dude it must take you
a long time i'm like
it really doesn't like it would be funny
if you did a satirical video where it's
like four hours
like i get about five because that's
when my hair is perfect yeah it's like
three a.m vacation yeah
you eat certain things to like help your
hair oil to your hair broccoli is the
key yeah that would be fun do you like
the laser treatments on the hair like
the follicles like every morning if
someone come in
individually placing each hair yeah well
my 9am it's ready well like to your
point of the hair you know my
discord community was making all these
hair memes alex you know right when i
came in he's like dude i love the hair
memes yeah these guys are
they they take my hair to a whole nother
level i didn't think was possible i'm
like
you guys have too much time on your
hands but i love it let's talk about the
real estate market
talking a lot about hair and botox and
stuff you are the expert of real estate
here i thought you're going to say talks
no
not quite
cosmetic surgery
so everyone wants to know what's going
on with the real estate market because
we've seen a lot of fear in the market
some youtubers are talking about like
price reductions and stuff like that
that's going on what's your opinion of
all this look we've had the same
conversation since the very first iced
coffee every time you know we come on um
like look i'm buying as much as humanly
possible because this thing is gonna
keep going and then um
you know now it's kind of an interesting
time because the fed's been raising
rates and so
you know people are getting scared and
whatever right i'll say
in january i made a youtube video with
like my predictions for 2022 and i said
this is what i predict is going to
happen i think they're going to raise
rates in like march april it's going to
cause a negative effect in the stock
market people are going to start
panicking and doing all this stuff and
then they're going to reverse course and
lower rates again you know q3 q4 like
that's still today what i predict will
happen and even if that doesn't happen
let's just say they keep rates where
they are i don't see them continuing to
race rates the market still is just so
hot it doesn't matter like
if you compare it to
two months ago or whatever sure like
it's slowing down in comparison to that
but like here in vegas there's still
been less than a month of inventory you
know like if if you were to go into like
a pure
like the market is tanking you would
need
four or five months of inventory to do
that so unless you believe
you know five times the amount of houses
are gonna flood the market
nothing's gonna happen like as far as
price is declining or anything like that
so my opinion is
i think that yeah it won't keep you know
moving at the speed of lightning like
it's been for the last two years it's
gonna definitely grow slower but i still
think it's going up do you think there's
a chance that now maybe affordability is
kind of tapped out
rates are going up
sellers might have to now begin to lower
their asking prices because they're
competing with other people if they need
to sell they're going to sell
if rates go up affordability goes down
lower prices and that could start a
trend
well let's talk about lowering prices
because we lower prices on our flips too
um
for the last two years
we've been pricing things like stupid
asking prices you know we don't price it
at market value and try to get a bidding
war like these houses we're buying you
know we originally thought let's just
say it was gonna get 450 grand and then
by the time we list we're looking at it
we're like oh man one just sold for you
know 480 right like that's great but
we're still like let's list it at
freaking 525 because we just
know people have been paying it the last
two years so
will we still take that kind of strategy
as it slows down no we're not going to
price as aggressive right
and currently if we've priced this thing
at 525 and we thought we were gonna sell
it for 450
you know
it
yeah we drop it to 500 and it still goes
over and sets a new comp like that's
what we're seeing um
so yeah i think price reductions are a
bit of a myth because people are over
pricing them so high compared to comps
that like
oh you got to price it
closer to comps now like
it's still a crazy market but first we
need to thank our sponsor ftxus ftx is
the most complete crypto and finance app
out there it allows users to buy and
sell crypto and nfts with no fees
whatsoever ftx is one of the largest
cryptocurrency exchanges in the world in
terms of daily uses and trading volume
and they got a valuation of roughly
eight billion dollars you might have
heard of ftx through their partnerships
with steph curry tom brady coachella or
the miami heat arena you see most
exchanges charge two to three dollar
minimum fees on every transaction but
with ftx you can trade as much as you
want all for free they even offer a
crypto friendly debit card allowing you
to spend crypto at millions of merchants
worldwide and their founder sam bankman
freed plans to give away 99 of what he
personally makes to charities and they
also make things like dollar cost
averaging easy with things like
recurring buys where they can pull money
directly from your bank account on a
weekly bi-weekly or monthly basis and
invest it for you automatically so start
trading crypto and nfts with no fees by
downloading ftx down below in the
description once again that's ftx
there's a link down below in the
description to start trading with no
fees today thank you so much ftx and now
back to the podcast a big thing that's
happening that didn't happen in
you know 2008 is that you have all these
hedge funds buying houses now right like
single-family homes weren't an asset
class before this
and
you know when these hedge funds are
buying these homes what people don't
realize is they're taking them off the
market completely like that home is gone
the moment you sell it to them because
they're not relisting it trying to go
flip it or anything they're holding it
for the next
five ten years who knows right
and when they hold it
you know they're building up their
portfolio they're not gonna go sell it
on the mls when they're ready to sell
they're gonna go sell it to another fund
like so that that house just never comes
back on the market and that's why these
funds are still buying so heavily
because they just know every single day
houses are being picked off the market
for like good and we're not being we're
not able to build quick enough or cheap
enough to replace that house
and so
right now you're just seeing this weird
dynamic that's never existed in the
history of housing where
they're literally being removed from the
market completely because they're not
owned by normal people anymore yeah but
how many how many hedge funds and
institutions are really out there buying
these single-family homes from all the
research i could find
everything points to that being
mostly a myth
institutional investors for
single-family homes are like 0.01
to the market and they're buying up
single-family homes but in communities
or in bulk in certain areas that were
specifically designed or made to be
rentals so they're not like you know yes
your checklist is house and blackrock
isn't going and like looking at jack's
house but they are so
i mean we've sold a bunch to hedge funds
like just normal flips we already
flipped them and you know like renovated
them and they paid over every normal
buyer what sort of hedge funds are you
seeing
they're just like
normal hedge funds that like are keeping
them as rentals like
i don't know the exact hedge funds by
name but like we've sold a bunch of edge
funds and so like we'll also wholesale
to hedge funds where we don't even fix
it up right they're like we want to buy
this right now before you ever let it
hit the market and so we just sell it
direct to them
um what you're referring to is build for
rent which is a very small niche thing
like when they do these build for rent
communities um those are really cool but
yeah they they are very niche but um i
would say also too it depends on the
market you're in
most hedge funds are looking in places
like vegas and phoenix and really nice
markets and climates and newer homes
they love that so like vegas is a very
heavily
impacted market by hedge funds i just
have not seen and again you're in it so
you see like where these offers come i
have not seen anything that indicates
that hedge funds are buying up single
single-family homes
uh like one by one because even from my
perspective going in and like
negotiating because to buy one house
doesn't make sense for a hedge fund
right they would have to buy probably 50
to 100 houses yeah going through and
negotiating 50 different homes 50
different inspections 50 different um
uh
rentals it just it doesn't make sense
on like when they're scattered around
the city if they're just if their
objective is to buy as much as possible
yes and i'll send you this is an email
yesterday yeah from um one of the
largest hedge funds
and um
you know basically they're just
outlining
what it is they really want in their
portfolio
yeah but but these are this seems like
more like a wealthy individual who's
like going out and trying to build a
portfolio no that's what he wants you to
think
because you're more likely to sell to a
small investor than you are to a hedge
fund as like a mom-and-pop person like
even for us
we we try to do it more personable um
like with our postcards it's it's me and
my family and so it's like me and my
family we want to buy your house
and they're like oh that's cute you know
this guy wants to support his family and
buy the house and it's like
i'm not even big right but if i had a
big corporate thing of like you know
home run offers buying houses it would
perform worse than if it was a real
personal
thing with my kids my wife and all that
so what you saw is exactly what they're
doing um
that company i showed you is like you
said the biggest buyer in vegas i mean
they're buying so many houses it's nuts
but i'm curious what company that is
and it's it's to me it seems like it's a
local company who's going and buying
these and not like some big institution
to know what these are publicly traded
on the market or anything like that well
what these institutions do is um they
partner with
local brokers like that guy and they
just do this in every single state
i'll show you after this sure but um
yeah i think
not even if you take out the hedge funds
which is a big portion of this
the other side of it is just homeowners
in general right now so
you know it's like man if you sell your
house
the big question is not how much you're
going to make like you're going to make
a ton everyone's got equity
but where are you going to move
that's the problem and so when you have
this issue of affordability like you
said
um somebody who maybe bought a house
five years ago
would love to sell but they can't
because they can't buy anything after
the fact they'll have all this money but
they either can't qualify for a mortgage
or they don't want to deal with the
headache of moving and so now
that can constrain supply because these
people can't move because they can't buy
and so like if you take out these people
now
you you take out these hedge fund buyers
you take out
um
you know like just where where's the
inventory gonna come from like i don't
know and that's why when i look at it
i'm saying
okay maybe even if demand goes down
because people are like i can't afford
this right still where's the supply
gonna come from it's not only just where
you're gonna move to but it's also now
you're getting a higher interest rate
than you are probably locked into now so
like jack you got like a 2.8 if you sold
and you bought another house just an
equivalent house or even something a
little bit more that monthly payment is
going to be so much higher yeah so a lot
of people in that position are just
going to say that's probably better to
stay jack would you ever sell right now
would i ever well no like right now this
very moment no
why
because i know i got a fantastic rate
and plus i want to acquire more real
estate rather than offload what i
currently have right so
another point right it's like
you can't buy something else because
it's too expensive the rates are higher
whatever right you're locked into this
great deal of an interest rate so people
are less likely to sell because they got
a great rate something that was
interesting that we discussed with
jeremy when we had him on is like people
in my age group that are looking to buy
real estate they've never seen higher
rates like maybe you or graham have seen
and for me to see you know i locked in
2.874 back in october and now it's
almost double that now and it's just
like you know half a year later it's
just like i'm i can't even process it
i'm like oh my gosh like i do not want
to get anywhere near buying another
piece of property because it just seems
like it the rates are so high but right
historically not not necessarily yeah i
when i got into 2010 the rates were
around five percent at that time and um
i know that back in
before that you know seeing rates at six
seven you know eight percent wasn't
crazy and then i remember my mom telling
me like yeah five percent is really
cheap it's a great rate like get on it
and um yeah i've watched it over the
years go to four and then when they did
all this stuff to see things in the twos
blew my mind i'm like
i can't believe people are getting two
percent rates like this is nuts um so
yeah i mean for me i don't mind paying
five percent like i'm still buying
rental properties and um
i'm fine with those rates and if rates
go back down like i think they will if
it makes sense i'll just refi and you
know do that but i want to acquire
rentals why don't you go into developing
properties instead of flipping
yeah so um development is
very lucrative
as of today right these developers who
started projects two years ago
they're getting way more than
anticipated um i had one of my students
actually just text me
he's doing a development of like 10 lake
houses and um hey where is he at he's
like somewhere in the south
um and he was like dude we already got
two offers on these houses that aren't
even done like 200 grand down
non-refundable like they want them
and he's like we're gonna make like 400k
more than we projected on these million
dollar houses in the span of like you
know a year so it's crazy just what's
happening in development on that side
and then you see all the development
with you know commercial real estate you
know you look in las vegas commercial
real estate's going around everywhere
you know people are not stopping i would
say for me
the reason i'm not doing development
other than my personal home which i'm
doing development on
is i mean you can only do so much in
real estate right like so my focus is on
um obviously it's been flipping and
wholesaling these last bunch of years
and now it's you know on the fund and
buying apartments across the country and
um we could certainly do development but
um
i don't know it's just like
it's super lucrative but it's not the
capacity to worry about it right now one
thing that i was telling uh jack when we
had shelby on the podcast was that um
i stayed in yosemite at this airstream
park um
it was insane so they have this huge
plot of land right outside of yosemite
and there are 85 of these like mobile
home you know airstreams yeah exactly
and each one rents for about 300 to 400
a night there's 85 of them yeah they're
correct and plus plus they got like a
little center club house where they sell
like food and snacks and coffees and
stuff like that i was estimating this
place is probably pulling in about eight
to ten million dollars a year
and net they they're probably at like
five million bucks yeah a year doing
something like that yeah so um
i had this girl on my podcast her name's
heather blankenship and um she's
actually a part of future flipper and
stuff now doing some really cool things
but she has these glamping resorts um
across the country and when she was
first telling me about the podcast this
was like over a year ago she's like yeah
you know we have these tents and stuff
and um you know we get like 300 bucks a
night i'm like who's paying 300 for a
tent like what do you mean
and she was like it's not a tent like
you think like it's a it's a house you
know that
you know it's really nice it's got a
bedroom it's got a living room and
the whole glamping thing is nuts because
it's so cheap to do it's an experience
people want they're willing to pay a lot
you know to get it and all you really
need is land and some utilities like
it's not you don't even need the air
streams you know people are doing this
with tents and
stuff yeah the tents they had were
actually really nice exactly yeah what's
your opinion on like modular homes
because i've been also looking into that
for me it sounds really cool to be able
to just buy a plot of land that's owned
residential and then just throw in like
you know a prefab home or something like
that or five of them next yeah that's
what i'm saying and create like a little
commune i know that they also sell on
home depot or in home depot like
basically you know
sheds that can be livable and they're
like 30 30 grand yeah
so
i've learned so much about modular homes
over the years like way more than i ever
thought to imagine so
we've been flipping mobile homes um here
in vegas for a long time and so
i remember i used to be able to buy a
mobile home with land for like 50k we
would try and go flip it for like 80k it
was great i mean dude these same mobile
homes now in vegas they're selling for
like 300 grand like it's nuts and so um
your plan of like buying land and
putting a mobile home on it
in vegas is going to cost you like 300
grand um
that's just where prices are so i mean
maybe you buy it out there but um we
ended up getting our mobile home
dealer's license my partner and i
because we were buying so many mobile
homes and i was getting a bunch that
were just terrible and i was like you
know what like let's scrap them and
throw a new mobile home on there we
don't have to do any renovation we don't
we'll just throw the mobile home on
there and um at the time when we got it
it was gonna be like around a hundred
grand to like do a legit like 1500
square foot double wide brand new
everything you know the shipping the
foundation all the things you needed to
do
um we ended up never doing it because it
just was a lot of work and like that
same 50 grand mobile home um we were
able to just go flip it for like 80. and
so we were like ah why even deal with
all this it's just not really worth the
headache or the risk but like that's
what mobile homes are today as far as
like owning the land with them in these
places in vegas you know like what um
our friend brandon turner is doing yes
he's buying mobile home parks across the
country i invested in one oh nice yeah
nice
so yeah so i'm i'm actually a one-tenth
owner now of a mobile park his mobile
home park yeah
i have no idea yeah yeah he had an
allocation and uh asked me if i wanted
to uh go in i was like you know what why
not he sent me the deal and i really
liked it a lot can you walk us through
the numbers
uh
yeah i
have to pull it up yeah while you pull
it up i'll explain so like the mobile
home parks are cool because you don't
own the mobile homes themselves i mean
you can but
all you do is you own the land and then
people pay you lot rent on all of these
mobile homes on there and so um so they
move their mobile homes onto that land
yeah or you might already have one there
because it it came with the land or
somebody left it or whatever um and then
you can charge more because you've
already got a mobile home forum
is mobile home zoning different than
like actual like you know yeah you can't
just go through a mobile home wherever
you want yeah so it still has to be
zoned for the same amount of capacity of
like residential you know houses or
whatever yeah and i mean it's just you
have to be able to um
you know if you've got a plot of land
you know in the middle of this nice
neighborhood in summerlin or something
you know you can't just go throw them in
there
yeah
um i actually thought the reason i know
that's because i thought about it was
like what would happen if i just did
this yeah but no they won't let you
mobile homes are interesting in that way
but like
even today you you won't believe this
but there are luxury homes that are
built modularly and so yeah yeah i've
seen those my house that um i'm actually
moving into now not the house i'm
building um on the mountain but this
other house that i bought as a flip i
paid 1.8 million dollars for it and you
know it's worth over 3 million once we
get it fixed up and stuff but you know
it looks like a normal modern house it's
super cool
and
all of a sudden like the guy starts
telling me he's like yeah you know this
is a modular home i was like this is why
like what do you mean like how was a
you know three million dollar home a
modular home he's like well you know
half of the house is built um
you know as a normal stick build and
then there's this half of the house that
is you know they brought in they
imported these different modulars and so
there's like five pieces that came you
know in these modular and you would
never know like there's no way you would
ever know unless he told you
but
i realized it
um by actually looking at the walls and
so like the door frame if you look at
the door frame right out here right you
know it's like
six inches
well these door frames were like this
big and i was like why is the door frame
and wall so big that doesn't make any
sense
well the reason was they were attached
that was where the seam was for the
modular and so it has to be thicker to
support it and do all that so i was like
oh
that makes sense
huh yeah yeah those luxury modular homes
are really cool and they make ones with
like big glass sliding doors and stuff
like that and it's still like relatively
cheap for what you're getting yeah i
don't know why the guy
did that but
you know i got a good deal on it for a
reason i guess i don't know
yeah here's the the deal maybe don't
give too much detail out just because i
don't know how much of it is public yeah
uh but basically for 3.2 million
uh they're expecting overall i think the
the
total return over the next 10 years is
gonna be somewhere on like almost 20
percent a year
it's pretty high yep the advantage of
this is that you could do some mass
depreciation up front yup which is
really good so let's say if you for
every dollar you invest you're able to
write off like a dollar to a dollar
forty yep uh in depreciation which is
really attractive and then also um their
plan was to um
not only fix up the uh the area and just
make it more inviting i mean it it was
not run properly so a lot of things were
just degrading and not properly taken
care of so with his team he's going to
go in there and make sure everything is
properly taken care of and then also
what i really liked about brandon turner
was that he really wants his tenants to
uh
grow their wealth
and invest in where they live and so
oftentimes with his tenants instead of
him trying to like raise rents
he'll host these events that teach about
financial literacy and ways for them to
eventually buy the place that they're
living and so long term they'll be the
owner
and so part of that was he intends to
sell those units if they could afford
them or if they want to buy them so
instead of them renting they could own
them
and then that works out for them and it
works out for brandon and his fund
because now it's one less thing that
they have to manage for upkeep well and
also too it makes that tenant more
sticky because now that they own that
mobile home they're not leaving yeah i
really like not having to uh to worry
about it like i trust brandon explicitly
mm-hmm and it's just like
here's my money
i trust you man how much did you give
him uh 300 000 so you should get like 60
grand a year from that effectively yeah
over eight years but that also includes
the sale the sale right so up until the
sale i'll be getting anywhere between
like seven percent to ten percent a year
yeah which i don't i don't care i mean
just i see the long-term right off yeah
you're gonna get the big payday at the
end like that's how all syndications
work like you know you're gonna cashflow
a little bit throughout the play and
then the hope is that you have a big
exit or a big refi where you get your
money back and then
um you know you've got this property
that you own with no money in the deal
yeah and that's actually what we've what
what ryan and i have done which is which
is odd because it's uh i've wanted to
when we had alex hormozy on here he was
telling me you got to do like a real
estate fund yep and i told him i didn't
want to do the work on that because it's
i i've just seen how much work is
involved behind the scenes of like
managing i couldn't possibly do that so
when you reached out to me it was
actually really cool because i talked to
brandon turner about potentially
partnering with him on a fund uh because
i really like brandon turner a lot i
know he has a good eye for things and we
we had a good talk and
you know he is just so inundated and he
just like i can't do anything like so
when you called me and said hey i think
we could work together i was really
excited about it yeah dude i was too so
it's funny because i've talked to
hormozy
quite a bit um him being here in vegas
and stuff and you know somebody had sent
me the podcast you did with them they're
like dude hermozy's telling graham he
needs to start a fun you know you should
reach out to graham and i was like all
right let me go watch this and so you
know i watched and i'm like all right
graham dude are you ready
like and then you're like yeah it was
just like a very good thing yeah i said
give me 24 hours yeah because i had told
brandon turner that he had priority yep
and i wasn't going to do anything
without brandon turner's permission on
that because i didn't want to feel like
you know i'm ever like going around
someone so i called them yeah and uh he
spoke very highly of you by the way yeah
brandon
yeah i love brandon dude we um
i mean i i've said this on bigger
pockets and you know just with him like
he's the reason i've been able to have
success in real estate like
it was his book i read um it was his
podcast i listened to that gave me the
start and so you know i'm forever
grateful to him and then being able to
you know i've been in hawaii multiple
times and hung out with him and he's
always like dude if you ever want to
come the basement's open like his place
is so cool yeah he's just nice he's the
man yeah and um
yeah so it's funny because uh he you
know we all share the same lawyer we
were just talking to our lawyer um
monday right and
he had been telling me to start a fund
at some point and then my other friend
told me and i'm like all right fine
we're gonna do this and so last year we
did it and um
you know we bought 460 units um there
and then you know when i saw her mosey's
podcast with you you know i reached out
and i'm like look i think there's a way
that we can do this even bigger you know
if we work together we've already got
all these relationships with all these
operators and guys finding deals across
the country and um in fact you know we
turn down a lot of deals that i think
would be great for a different fund
because um you know for us we want the
pieces of crap that are just so beat up
and like you know the last thing we
bought was 126 units it's literally zero
vacancy or it's um zero vacancy yeah
zero occupy there's no one there yeah
like we like it we wanna fix that up and
make a lot but um there's a ton of great
deals that you know are doing well and
there are ways to add value to them but
like we just were like man our thing is
we want to go with these home run type
deals but there's so many doubles out
there doubles triples that could become
home runs too
if we just took him down and so as when
i reached out to him like i think
if we partnered your audience would eat
up these deals that we're just turning
down that are great and so um dude i
think we're going to do a lot of good
stuff because i was telling ryan too i
would much rather
a safe predictable return than something
that's a home run 10 years from now i
would just rather just feel better about
consistency i agree yeah and
i mean that's why i'm so excited about
it because we are getting sent those all
the time and there's i mean right when
we you know we're like let's do this
paper fast i was blown away within 24
hours you're like all right we're going
to get all this done yeah and by the end
of the week you're like here's the
paperwork yeah like not like that
obviously not that tone but like here
you go grab sign it here's our logo
here's our website i was shocked how
fast you moved on all this i mean i
wouldn't expect anything else but like
it was faster than i
thought was possible yeah um but then
you brought us the deal in st louis can
you tell us about that i was telling
jack there's like a brewery in the
bottom that i was really excited about
yeah so this this is the beauty of
having um you know coaching program and
a big mastermind so like my students are
nationwide right and they're always
hunting for deals everywhere and so with
them um you know they have a harder time
raising capital than you or i would have
and so this deal actually came from one
of my students in st louis um he's
flipping a lot of houses he's a gc on
commercial real estate projects and
stuff and he was like dude
ryan need to look at this deal like it's
um
it's around like 80 units or something
in st louis and um there's this really
hip bar
um at the bottom that you know everyone
all the locals love going to it's like
renovated and it's super cool and
there's uh like this other space that's
empty that we could you know do whatever
we want with that's also cool and we
started looking at the numbers and you
know i was like all right this is a
really cool deal like it's already
occupied it's stable it's good and um
you know there's some other things we
can do to add value um
and you and i were talking and we had
just you know finalized our our deal and
i was like dude this would be a great
first one for um creator properties so
i'm excited about that one yeah
oh that's the name of it it's called
creator
yeah yeah that's cool yeah yeah guys if
you want a hot take i didn't like the
name i'm gonna be honest no it sounded a
little gimmicky no really yeah
i'm just gonna be honest because it's
like because you could have a dual
meaning like a creator isn't a creator
on on youtube or wherever but it could
also be like creators and like you're
creating these opportunities yeah well
alex
can't win them all well you can invest
alex you know what guys you know what
else don't watch it anyway i i can't
even invest in itself yeah you've got to
be an accredited investor is that the
requirement is being an accredited
investor yeah you have to be a credit
investor and for those that don't know
what is an accredited investor um so you
gotta have a million dollar net worth or
um income of 200 000 for the last two
years yep or if you're married um i
think it's 300 000 the last two years as
a joint couple and are there other
ins potentially for those that don't
meet those requirements because i may
know someone
so there's actually check your house is
worth two million dollars right yeah
it's worth two million dollars verify
that i mean so we use third party oh
okay so we don't you know if you guys
apply it creator properties we're not
gonna verify we're going to send you to
a third party accreditation they're
going to be the ones who decide got it
do you guys have it do you guys have a
minimum like an investment amount um
typically we do about 50k just because
you know at the end of the day you don't
want to have so many investors in one
deal like it's just more paperwork it's
right if you're an accredited investor
like
you should have more capital anyway
right what do you think about the name
jack
be honest
creator properties creator properties
okay so i will be honest be honest
i thought it was a touch gimmicky
because creator properties it's just
like it's kind of a little bit easy of a
name and i'm not gonna say but here's
the thing yeah
there is a little bit of a double
entendre which you know i like yeah i do
like that i know and overall i think
realistically that's a great way to
market especially like if you're
marketing on
youtube predominantly creator properties
it just goes in line what was the first
name that we thought of that we both
really liked it was so when i was just
randomly telling graham like okay so
here's the deal you know we're going to
start this creator capital
and um oh is that it yeah it was just
capital i really liked that name yeah
he's like where'd you come up with that
and i was like it's just like the
placeholder name until creator capital
honestly sounds like something coffee
would make coffeezilla would make a
video
it just sounds like that does it not
like
you know what i think jack summarized my
thoughts like pretty much perfectly i
agree with everything jack said um i
think it's great for branding and i i
think it's a good move just ted
alex what'd you think of the logo the
logo i actually liked uh it i mean
because it made sense with the name
and i thought that it it was great for
branding so the logo i think you guys
nailed it uh just not sure if i liked
creative properties but you know it's
growing it's growing on me is it too
late to change the name
we stuck with this
[Laughter]
it's always fun coming up with names
like that's my favorite part of business
i like that really you know coming up
with them and the logos and the branding
and all that stuff and uh when i was
trying to think of names i'm trying to
think like how does this relate to
graham and what like has made graham who
he isn't successful it's like man if you
think of graham you're like this guy is
the best creator like yeah
you know what's funny uh when i set up
my first llc
thank
thankfully jason uh oppenheim talked me
out of this but uh i was sitting at the
first one i think i was like this is
like 2014. and i came up with the name
real estate cash flow llc yeah just like
graham you're not doing that
why it's real estate cash flow he's like
that that is the worst
stupidest name do not do that
and he was like so against it i thought
like wow real estate casual it's cool
it's cool
it's so cringy like i even thought like
yeah and the reason we didn't go with
creator capital two was um obviously the
domains were taken and stuff but the
more i thought i'm like
how will they know it's real estate
right because like to me be like oh
creator capital we're gonna go fund
other creators and like buy
you know their their brands that makes
sense yeah and so i'm like how do we add
real estate to
you know being a creator and so that was
the mindset can you go over some of the
specifics on the uh st louis deal
oh man i don't have the numbers off the
top of my head um yeah i don't want to
butcher what we're doing with it but i
do know
we got a million dollar um credit for
the roof so
we got a million dollars off since we
got it too so let's say i am an
accredited investor why would i go and
do this instead of just go and buy a
property on my own and have all of that
control um multiple reasons so
you know if you go and buy a house
yourself i mean obviously you own it 100
and you're the one who has to deal with
everything you've got to find the deal
you've got to deal with the tenants the
maintenance et cetera right
when you invest in something like this
we're going to find the deal which we
have right here's the deal you can
choose whether or not you want to invest
in it
we're going to manage it we're going to
you know renovate it stabilize it all
this stuff and it's really passive for
you like you don't have to do anything
and so that's the benefit for most
people like graham what you know the
reason he invested with brandon in that
deal is that you know he's not doing
anything like he's just like take my
money
multiply it and i trust you and so
that's the benefit of a fund like a lot
of accredited investors um that invest
with
us on these deals most of them
aren't always real estate guys most of
them are doctors and
you know even influencers or uh you know
e-commerce people people who are not in
the real estate field but have made a
lot of money and they don't know how to
invest because they haven't made their
money investing they've made it like
doing a job and so for them they're they
just don't they wouldn't even know what
to buy in real estate and so they would
rather just um
go with the experts and not do anything
and focus on their their job that
actually makes them money
and how do the finances work out for you
like in the syndication like how how
would it so obviously you collect all
these people's money you put it into a
property the property sells at a premium
how do you distribute the money after
you sell the property different
percentage-wise i'm sure you guys have
some sort of you know bonus or something
that you guys take from the work yeah so
um we can break down just kind of how a
typical um syndication works so you have
gps and lps gps are your general
partners these are the people who are
you know me and graham we're finding the
deals we are underwriting them we're
getting everything prepared you know
once we buy it we're going to be the
ones managing it doing everything then
you have the lps which are the limited
partners those are the investors right
like they're they're not in charge of
doing any of that they just are in
charge of putting their money up and
then just kind of waiting and collecting
checks on the meantime
so
typically what happens is
your gps and lps will split the deal in
a certain percentage i mean it it varies
man just depending on how big the deal
is i mean you might see deals that are
50 50. you might see deals that are 70
30 80 20 like it really just depends on
how good the deal is and how it's
structured um but along with that the
lps will also get
a preferred return and so you know a
typical preferred returns anywhere from
six to eight percent
and um essentially
before anyone takes their profit split
the lps need to be paid that preferred
return first
and anything above that preferred return
then gets split up depending on how that
split goes so for easy sake let's just
say it's a 50 50 split and the property
is returning you know 12 percent
every month right now well if you have a
preferred return what will happen is the
lp will get eight percent first and
foremost before anybody
then the remaining four percent gets
split up 50 50 between the gps and the
lps and so what would happen is the lps
would make ten percent gps would make
two percent so as the gps on that side
were making two percent
but we also make monies in other ways
with gps i mean we have an acquisition
fee um you know a yearly management fee
but you know at the end of the day
honestly as a gp the big payday is at
the end
you know like the two percent every
month ain't doing much for us
but at the end you know let's just say
this uh st louis deal i don't know you
know it around 10 million dollars um
if it sells for 15 million dollars in
however many years
um you know as long as the lps got paid
their um
you know they're they're eight percent
all those years and stuff um basically
we would end up splitting the profit
from that and so that's how we make a
bigger payday so the gps would take
let's say two and a half million split
that amongst themselves and then the
remaining two and a half million would
just go to every lp investor yep and
then the lps have been making that eight
percent that whole time as well but of
course this is always subject to change
if it's a different structure
yeah yeah so like what what would
typically happen is like
if a deal is um more thin we always want
to make sure the lps get like the
desired return right so it's like man
grant graham is looking at like that 15
return on brandon's deal right 15 to 20
that's what he's looking at
he's not necessarily super concerned
about well how much is brandon making
you know he's like oh i'm making 15 20
like cool and so like to structure a
deal like that
you know you might have to give the lps
a big chunk of
the deal you might have to give them 80
um to achieve that return that you're
trying to get from but maybe you got
like a super crazy deal and you don't
need to give up that much because
the deal is so good you know you can
split it up differently because
everybody wants to invest in it you know
so it's just like anything else it's
kind of supply and demand and you just
kind of take it on a deal by deal basis
and say like okay first and foremost
what's my lp's desired return you know
on this and so how do we structure it to
get them that and do the gps put up any
capital in the beginning to like
own a certain percentage or whatever of
the yeah so um
obviously we have all of our startup
costs with this and everything we're
doing on the legal side and everything
so we front all of that we front the
earnest money deposits in fact i didn't
even tell you this graham but um on the
arizona deal that we're doing i just
sent 100 grand for the earnest money
deposit so you know we have those
upfront costs
and then typically what happens is
a lot of the banks that we're doing
these deals with want to see skin in the
game from the gps and so like in gram
and i's partnership essentially we're
gonna put in whatever they want us to
put in you know equally and so
you know on this deal the banks might
say hey graham and ryan we want you guys
to put in 100 grand each into this deal
you know for us to fund it and so you
know we'll do whatever we got to do
and then um we'll actually make um you
know the preferred return on that eight
percent as if we were just investors on
it too
yeah and when you do buy these big
properties you buy them with debt right
so let's say you accept like two million
dollars and it's like a five million
dollar property or whatever like yeah
take out a loan yeah like let's just you
know this ain't low steel like let's
just say it's around 10 million dollars
total
you know we'll go and take a um
loan out for probably 70 ish of it so
we'll get a seven million dollar loan
we'll go raise three million bucks
and so that's kind of how it goes
and all the tax benefits and everything
is that dispersed amongst all lps or is
that how does that go about so this is
where you can get creative with it um
you can totally just
change how you want the depreciation and
the taxes to go on a deal-by-deal basis
so
you know let's just say graham and i buy
so many deals this year because we're
just
crushing it and everybody's happy um
what might happen is like we're like
dude we don't even need any more
depreciation like we're you know we've
got our taxes down to zero which would
be fantastic for graham well then we can
just start saying hey you know what
we're gonna start um giving all of our
depreciation to the lps because um we
don't really need it like it would be a
waste for us um so we can totally
manipulate deals that way or if like
you know let's just say we want to make
a juicier deal for lps right then you'd
include that in the terms and everything
yeah we would just manipulate it to give
them more depreciation and tax
advantages and structure the deal that
way how do people that make syndications
like
screw over lps because i know that some
to some people there could be kind of
like a bad idea you know bad connotation
towards syndications why do you think
that's there and what is done in those
situations that like can negatively you
know affect the lps well you know with
um
the type of fund we're doing you know
it's a 506 c so it's credit investors
only so
basically the reason that they do that
is because like accredited investors are
you know
big boys like they they know what
they're doing and like they know that
they're investing their own money at
their own risk and if they lose it it's
not going to be catastrophic like
they're obviously doing pretty well
um the reason they make it so strict on
506bs where they're they allow anyone
and everyone to invest is because those
people
you know might not be a savvy or
educated and so you know they hear
graham like dude i want to put my life
savings with graham i got ten thousand
dollars
and then all of a sudden they're just
like dude how's this deal doing like
because it's their whole life savings
and so that's why
you see most funds not i don't even want
to say most don't go that route but like
that's where you see a lot of the flack
is when you deal with that side of it
because most accredited investors are
busy like running their businesses and
their lives like they don't have time to
have you checked in like to worry about
the mobile home part no never yeah like
and that's what most investors that's
why they're investing
um
but i would say to protect them
um i mean first and foremost like
they're getting the preferred return so
like they're getting that interest
before anybody
so whatever cash flow is coming in
making sure that they get paid first on
it um but you know as far as like
protection it's just like any other
normal real estate deal you do like i
mean if things go south there is the you
know threat of a foreclosure and things
but i will say with what graham and i
are doing on a lot of the initial
purchases right we're having to
personally guarantee them and so
by us personally guaranteeing them right
we're on the hook if if anything goes
bad it's like ryan enough coffee zillow
yeah
well i mean honestly
yeah if anything goes bad it's obviously
then you step in
and so
just like with anything but i think the
biggest risk jack honestly is the lack
of liquidity and i think that's hard for
some people to overcome just knowing
that if they invest in a deal like this
the money is tied up for anywhere from
five to ten years they can't sell their
portion of unless if they negotiate out
some other like discounted deal or like
well how does that work right yeah yeah
so i don't want to go off topic but um
so okay just on the way it works today
on a normal fund if jack all of a sudden
you were accredited and you invest 100k
with us and you're like ryan dude i
really need the 100k because
um you know i'm going through something
or there's a big opportunity for me what
would happen is you'd come to us and we
would say okay jack like we'll try our
best to
see if there's any other investors in
the deal that want to take your place
and buy your shares right that would be
first thing we try and do
second thing we try to do is um go put
it like to our contacts of like people
that we know weren't in on that deal
like hey do you want to get in on this
deal now because jax doesn't want to so
we try to get you out that way you might
have to take a loss
you know as far as like
you know just to get liquidity like that
those are all scenarios or
you know potentially you know you've
been in this fund for two years it's
gone up a lot and it's getting ready to
exit but you're like i need to exit
early and so maybe you know you make a
little bit of money right that's what
would happen today um
what i've been making a lot of youtube
videos about and like something that
you know i'm working on heavily is my
nft project called tikes which is
basically getting ready for this digital
real estate revolution because what's
going to happen eventually
is they're going to nft funds like this
and it's already happening they're
companies that do it but they're going
to nft funds to solve that very issue of
liquidity because if everybody's share
was an nft
say for a hundred thousand dollars right
um instead of relying on me to try and
cash you out and be out of luck you'd be
able to sell that share like whenever
you felt like it right but maybe not to
an accredited investor or something like
that well what will happen on for the
accredited investor funds is there's
going to be intermediaries where you can
list it right you can list it on a
marketplace and the intermediary will
verify that the new buyer is accredited
you know they'll get their information
and do the transaction
but just being able to
make shares liquid is going to be huge
in the future and there's no reason like
that shouldn't be the way things happen
right because for us as gps
if you go show your sell your shares on
the open market it doesn't matter to us
like
we still have the property nothing has
changed on our end you've just
decided to either exit for liquidity or
you know maybe you think the market's
gonna crash next year but you know you
know we're not selling anytime soon
we're still getting it stabilized and
ready and um you're like dude you know
my hundred thousand i could probably go
sell it for 120 right now i'm just gonna
sell it and bounce and let somebody else
take the risk so that's going to happen
in the future for sure but why can't
that be done in the current way not
including the nfts i mean it would be
done the way i'm talking about where um
we would just go try to sell your shares
like i don't can't be sold on the open
market it's the same reason like when i
invest in a startup company
i can't just go and sell my shares
even if i want to
even if it's worth more it's against the
paperwork right
it's a long process and they would have
to it would be contingent on them
basically finding a replacement who
wants to buy it under the terms of
whatever the board is set
so it's it's the same as investing well
similar is investing in a startup
company that's illiquid or a privatized
company where shares are not trading
back and forth but in a way i think it
could work to people's favor because i
remember
uh in grant cardone's fund in 2020 right
as the covet shut down people were
panicking and wanting to
get rid of whatever they had with grant
cardone
and i remember him making these videos
telling people now we're holding uh you
know we need to we need to see this
through don't worry about it and there
are all these rumors about him like
selling his jet to going bankrupt but
those people that didn't sell
they've probably more than doubled their
money yeah just by not selling and so in
a way locking it up ensures that you're
able to hold on to it long enough to
increase the chances of coming out ahead
profitable well and
i saw an article from goldman sachs um
about a week ago where they talked about
how they're super bullish on digital
real estate like essentially they're
looking at real estate being you know
tokenized and traded just like stocks
for this very reason right you know
imagine instead of me hunting for deals
you know to buy the whole house i could
hunt for people you know who are trying
to sell their shares right now on great
projects they're like oh dude creator
properties has this great deal why does
this guy want to sell his stuff right
now like for whatever reason you're
listing it for sale and they're going to
be buying up these you know things and
so that will become more efficient as
time goes on 100
and that's going to be a full-on
industry of
trading
you know shares in these real estate
projects that makes sense yeah it sounds
like
something very interesting
i wonder if you could be accredited i
can't you need that extra a year yeah so
graham what we can do though okay for
all of our friends is
you know we could do
um a 506 b but we just can't market it
and so
what you know we could do with jack is
like let's just say we get a deal where
you know we're gonna raise million two
million bucks and we already know
jackson
we're gonna we might let alex in if he
changes his tone about creator
properties
burn
we might let him in um but you know
we'll have jeremy and kevin and all
these guys like they're andre they're
all like yeah we want in we don't even
need to advertise it right
well that in that case you can do you
know like a friends and family fun where
you can invest with us what if because
the st louis one man it sounds pretty
attempting to be can graham invest in
that and then after i file my next
you know return and then i become
accredited and then i hope
then he can sell his portion to me
a hefty profit jack there's a premium
for that my gut tells me that you can
but uh i'm not the lawyer god i'm not
trying to say that you can do that and
uh do anything to jeopardize us how
about how about jack and i
just uh pass our series 65
and then you guys drop that requirement
for us
the 50k a little bit you know and then
uh can you and jack just make more money
yeah can we like let's just do that
yes
can i can can i co-sign for jack as like
yeah it's an accreditation
you get like a sponsor sponsoring jack
he's the incredible investor like i'll
back him up
can i do that i would do because jack i
would i would i would gladly because i
was playing all of my money this year is
is well almost all of it is probably
going to go in in real estate funds this
year so like that's my goal it's like
everything i make and save goes right
back into the fun so like i would
i don't know if i'd even legal say like
oh i'll put money in and if you want to
buy my portion later maybe yeah
contingent if that is legal of course if
it is illegal i will not do it got it
but either way i will invest and maybe
if i feel like it and it's legal and you
can buy those funds as an accredited
investor and at a premium at a premium
i've got a profit a significant premium
then maybe i will possibly consider it
thank you grandma i really appreciate
you're welcome and you know what's funny
too about that graham is so
in most these deals i imagine we're
going to do a cost segregation to get um
you know the big tax benefits on these
deals so
if we did do that you would get the
depreciation that year you bought it
well jacqueline
jackson
so you'd actually not even need to sell
it for a premium because you already
took the huge bonus sell for discount
that's a good idea yeah discount i mean
you know that word discount like you
know the um the last podcast i was on
you were actually telling jack you know
jack hadn't bought his first house yet
and he was like ryan should i buy a
house i'm like yes and you're like the
market's so high right now i'm like buy
the house jack you played a big role in
me buying that property because someone
didn't want i'm not gonna say who didn't
want me to buy very very much so
i said he could save so much money by
not buying yeah and then by the time
he's ready to buy something he's going
to be in a different price point and i
guarantee had you waited probably
another year your price point would be
maybe double i agree but i also i once
would have gone up like yeah and also i
i wanted to have a place of my own and
since i moved in my own place i have
been able to use the space and the
people i've moved in to then do contract
work through and then increase my income
and then i agree with you
i am doing networking barbecues yes beef
is a write-off yeah yeah beef is a right
off he basically uses his entire house
as an office because yeah everyone that
lives there they we all work together oh
i love you yeah so he's got just like
everyone in one house and they all just
like it's incredible it's so nice to be
able to just knock on you know my my
brand manager's door hey man how's this
sponsorship doing that's how i felt with
jack living here it's just jack
yeah it's got a podcast
that was something different
but yeah it's super nice in my editor i
just knock on his door hey man how's the
video going i hated when i knocked on
his door yeah
he was impressed i always lock it and i
would have to i would send a text which
i'm fine with i would always lock it did
you ever try it did you ever try it
it was so annoying you would always lock
his door to his bedroom and his bathroom
the guest house though uh i would
basically just like i would startle him
that was the thing yeah
like 7 p.m
yeah
the reason i brought it up was because i
remember during that time graham was
like hey i will um i'll i'll spot you on
it like i'll i'll fund your down payment
whatever and you'll pay me interest and
so he's offering to do that again for
you dude what a good boss he really is
yeah he really if it's legal if it's
legal yes maybe
for a briefing i would do
all right cool
deal yeah what questions do you have on
uh
alex
i feel like honestly we addressed most i
know yes i was like jack was over there
like power housing through all the
questions that were going through my
head jack great yeah great job i just
wanted to make sure that they just did a
great webinar yeah good yeah i thought
that was honestly helped you guys
out a lot like the pitch was
very good give me a percentage
and you get it for um less of a premium
now cool thank you yeah but now the
other thing i really liked about this is
i think this was late 2020 i started
looking around for myself because i
wanted to not do a syndicate i wanted to
do something on my own and i i spoke
with a lender
and the lender basically told me you
could you could
buy something in between six and twelve
and i'm like maybe if i if i wait a
little bit longer i could maybe push
that to like 15
and
i started looking around and calling
there was nothing and every single deal
it's it i was in this weird price point
where like by myself either i was
getting something that was needing a ton
of work like you were talking about
these home run deals
these are deals that like this is a year
of my life that i'd have to spend
renovating trying to rent it out it's a
full-time job for a year that i'd be
buying myself and then they're really
expensive places you're competing with
these deals that you know sure i could
afford it but i'm competing with people
who buy them all cash yeah and there's
no way that i could compete with like
some you know conglomerate or some
really rich guy who's like here's 15
million dollars cash seven day clothes
and i'm sitting there like sweating be
like this is this is everything like
what if it goes wrong we need a 30-day
inspection on it and so this was i at
least felt for myself i could mix in
between that i could get in that price
point with partnering with other people
who've done it before
in terms of the management side of
things because i've never managed
anything beyond a triplex yeah yeah i'm
excited for it dude i think um obviously
in
we've just
started you know it's only been a month
of really you know going through
everything but
already having two deals and there's
going to be many more like we're going
to buy a lot of real estate here in the
coming
in the i don't want to put a projection
on how much real estate we're going to
buy but
i think we're going to buy a lot
well jack you got to be accredited now i
know it's the next milestone no we'll
save one deal though for jack
everyone else we'll we'll keep that one
with the friends and family we'll link
to all the info down below in the
description for creator properties but
beyond that
how much money are you making ryan
okay and we're talking net to you so
this is like your portion at the end of
the day
after splits but before taxes and i'd
also like to know when you say how much
you're making how much is from each
different business because i know you
have like several different businesses
maybe too much for them to count yeah
you've got more businesses than fingers
and toes yeah there's no way i could um
just break them all off i'd have to look
at p l's from every single business and
you know with partners and stuff i don't
want to you know jump on their toes but
um
man my projection um this year has been
that i think we can do around 40 million
in gross profit and that's not counting
like
all the deals we buy like that's not
really profit that's just acquiring
units and different things like that
i would guess on that revenue after all
my partners and everything else
hopefully i could net around
15 million no
what has it been the last 12 months
because we have projections what'd you
put on your taxes yeah what's on your
taxes man how much is on there well
we're in the extension period of course
yeah
so yeah we haven't filed taxes yet but
um i would say last year net wise you
know i think i probably made five to six
mil now i'm not gonna pay tax on five to
six mil right we have all these
apartments we've bought all these
rentals like we're still working through
all that but and you just depreciate
that and cost segregate and stuff like
that
now what's taking that from five to six
to fifteen
where is that how does it double
um
well all the companies are growing you
know
pretty
rapidly um
you know education's growing we're we're
flipping more and more houses um
e-commerce is going well and then if
this whole nft thing and um tikes i mean
that could blow it out of the water
really so
really just having like multiple
ways to make money um
that i wasn't making revenue in before
right i didn't make money you know
within fts and digital real estate but i
think that's like a huge i mean that's a
trillion dollar like industry that is
going to happen right like there's no
doubt about it and so whoever creates
the businesses around that first is
going to capitalize like there's no
zillow for what we're talking about with
these um
shares of funds for nfts there's no one
like doing that at high level
um whoever does is gonna make a lot of
money as well as a whole bunch of other
services but so i would say it's coming
from all the existing businesses
continuing to grow
plus new streams of income like
nfts creator properties um buying more
apartments and that type of stuff and
what's interesting to me is that you
have so many businesses under like the
umbrella of like ryan pineda
how do you build such an effective team
underneath you and also last time we
spoke you said you only work what was it
like seven hours a day six hours a day
how are you able to accomplish so much
in such little time
you know i think it just comes down to
building an organization like the right
way um
you know i i know i've watched a bunch
of guys podcasts like i've seen um
hormozy speak and ryan sirhon speak and
you know all these guys like it's true
the moment you start scaling and
building out the organization to kind of
function without you
like you don't necessarily have to do
all this stuff you know so it's like i
used to go
on all the seller appointments myself
and close deals you know i haven't done
that in years right
if i wanted to raise money i used to be
the one calling the investors trying to
raise money it's like i don't do that
anymore right we have people who do that
i used to go to the houses and manage
the construction and the projects i
don't do that you know like even in the
education space um
you know that was something graham was
uh
we were talking about maybe months back
when i first
we first met like that company
you know i think last month we did like
600 grand pretty much organic and you
know e like info has really high margins
like you don't
you know it's super high margins but
like even in um coaching
you know it's like how do i build this
so that's not me always having a coach
how can i empower other coaches and
teach them what i know and like have
them coach and hold people accountable
and
you know all this stuff so
um i think all the businesses are built
in that same way where it's like i'll be
there initially like really building it
out the way it needs to be you know the
same way like when we did creator
properties i was with graham you know
every day like hey what do you think of
this logo what do you think of this name
here's the website what how are we going
to change the wording and all this stuff
okay great here's these first initial
deals like here's the lawyers like
really laying the groundwork but once we
do that we don't have to do that again
like it's done
at that point you know now the machine
is built and now you just plug deals
into it you know and it's just a process
we get a deal
we talk about it we send it to investors
they invest
you know then we manage and then you
just keep doing it over and over again
so whatever product or service we're
selling um if you just build the process
and you have really good people that can
execute that process over and over again
and adapt as markets and you know things
change
it doesn't really require you too much
you know like i said this from the
beginning with content
um
for me
i still have yet to edit a video like i
don't edit i don't post them anymore i
don't make my thumbnails or anything
else could i do better if i like put all
my my time and focus into doing that
absolutely like it we could do better
but for one i don't want to do that and
two
by not doing it allows me to do all
these other things and when there are
random fires in the different businesses
that you own do you still find yourself
having to step in and put them out
sometimes or do you have people that are
able to solve any issue that may come up
because i've noticed with me you know i
do have an editor and i do have
an assistant but when
things when they're struggling and they
can't find a solution to something i
constantly have to find myself to still
step in review certain things and i
can't fully detach myself from the stuff
that they're doing which i feel like
would ease my mind a lot
it doesn't save that much time but for
me not having to think about these
certain little things that happen on the
day on a daily basis would really i feel
like spur my creativity what's been
what's your experience been like with
that
so this is also why i'm like a big
advocate of delegating and building this
out the right way because it does give
you the ability to have like free time
and actually be creative like you just
said so um
you know right now my schedule for the
last you know i don't even know your
plus has been
monday to thursday ten to five at the
office friday i golf weekends or with
the family like it hasn't changed right
you know tomorrow i'm actually i told
you guys it's like we had to film today
because i'm taking the family to malibu
for the next five days and i was in the
dominican last week
and it's just like
the businesses still turn along like we
still got creator properties up and
going we still flipped houses and did
things and so it's like
you gain freedom by creating systems and
hiring great people and it cost you
money to do that you know i've paid
millions and millions of dollars in
salaries
but it's well worth it to to gain my
time freedom
and
for me it's not about making the most
money
it's really just about doing what i want
to do every day and you know doing the
things i love and then also building at
least as far as business goes
sustainable things that don't need me
you know so if i were to die tomorrow
you know i would hope that you know my
tax company would still function without
me which it does like i don't do taxes
like they're good without me um i would
hope that you know my education company
which um
most people is it's tied to them and it
still is like i'm the face for sure
but as far as like training people and
like executing it doesn't need me like
it will run just fine without me we
might suffer on sales because you know
i'm not now talking about it and uh
whatever but i have faith that the
leadership in place would figure out a
way to go generate leads without me you
know have a different face
promote one of our students who is you
know a good marketer a good leader and
you know one of our coaches whoever and
you've found all these different
businesses that you've built out to be
100
automated you don't ever have to dip
into them and like i said put out fires
well no i don't want to say i don't ever
have to dip into them um what i do is
like really from the sidelines like i
see myself more like a
i guess
general once it's established once it's
starting like when i first start a
business i'm like all in
building that out but once it's built
out and the right people are in place
then i kind of become like a general
where you know every week
you know my sister she sends me the
report on every single company
she's like here's how much revenue they
did you know we have different kpis that
i'm tracking like i want to know how
many deals did we get this week right um
how close are we to raising the money on
this you know fund deal that we're doing
um
you know how many students signed up how
many whatever and so i get all these
metrics every single week from her and
then i'm able to look at them and say
okay that's like on par like we're close
to hitting our quarterly goal um okay
what's up with this why is this so far
behind
and
you know i'll get the story and then
i'll be like okay well what are we going
to do to fix it
and you know from there
she kind of executes that and so the way
we're structured now
is like each individual company has its
own co and it has its own organizational
chart right and so that ceo's job is to
strictly run that specific company and
with that they get a percentage of net
profit whether they're a pro whether
they're a partner or not because i want
them equally incentivized like if we win
as a whole i want them to win like i
don't want to just be on salary like
doesn't matter what the company does so
i always have a net profit split
with all my cos
but from there what i started to realize
as we grew was that
these companies weren't communicating
good enough together because if we
learned something that worked well
for sales or marketing in one company
they weren't communicating it to the
other company right because they're kind
of just worried about their own thing um
and i started to think like man dude
you know
every time we need a website made or an
ad or like hiring a new sales person or
some tech
like each one
has to individually go figure this out
and i was like dude
it's time to like create this parent
company or this shared resource company
and you just like it wasn't any new
revolutionary idea i had it was just
something that i've seen
from big companies right like you know
google has alphabet and alphabet feeds
youtube it feeds every other company
that they have and um it's kind of like
this shared resource where youtube can
communicate with google drive and all
their other things so at this parent
company level or shared resource level
you know we hired
all of the people that um
all the companies need but don't really
need like on a full-time individual
basis so
we got
legal
finance
um sales trainer
our media buyer our graphic designer for
the websites our
tech development team for any softwares
or you know crm stuff whatever we need
um and then just like operations for
that company and so like on that shared
resource company you know i pay over 100
grand a month in salaries
because it's just
so strong and so like when we wanted to
go create um all the stuff for creative
properties they told grandmas they go
all right you know we'll get it set up
and you know it's going to be way
cheaper than if we were to go hire out
all these people initially because we
already have it all in place and so
immediately
logo was made website was made copy was
raised fast like everything was so quick
because the parent company already has
all those people but they're all
that's not a salaried employee that's
like more contract work no they're all
salaried employees full-time wow
yeah because and think about all my
companies need this stuff on a daily
basis yeah
hmm that's yeah so instead of hiring
someone um or hiring an outside company
ryan's like uh he just basically creates
his own company to do it yeah because he
needs someone to clean the toilet he's
like i'm gonna make a toilet cleaner
cleaning company we need that well like
i was telling graham you know car wash
company we're gonna need an investor
relation person um for creator because
there's
going to be so many people that want to
invest right we're going to have to talk
to all these leads and so
instead of being like graham do you know
anybody who wants to work for us as
investor relations um first thing we do
is i forgot to mention we have hr at the
parent company level so hr has a process
for posting a job you know like if you
guys watch my instagram stories you'll
see whenever we post
constantly hiring i don't post that
right there's a process for a job
posting and then there's the interview
and then there's everything else and
then what happens like for a sales
position is
the final check would be interviewing
with our sales manager in the parent
company because he knows
like what we need and the beauty is
maybe that sales person doesn't fit good
for creator you know they're not savvy
enough for funds or whatever else but
they might be a good salesperson for
you know
home run offer or future flip or
whatever right and so he has all of
these candidates of sales people and
we're able to place them if we really
like them for something else and so you
know it just kind of merges this whole
ecosystem together but then it also
allows us to really um
you know do cross sales and other things
because people don't realize like
oh well if you invest with us you need
tax
you know do you want to talk to one of
our accountants and see if we're a good
fit for you it you know it doesn't cost
you anything and it's like yeah sure and
then you know it could be revenue if
they end up signing up with us so that
parent company will end up paying for
itself like easily just from
just being better so you see a lot of
crossover from your clients but amongst
businesses 100 i i would say most people
um who are our client are a client in
multiple companies interesting yeah i
saw you were looking for a personal
assistant right yeah posted that on
instagram so how does this work so if
someone applies they go through your hr
what if someone comes to you is like
ryan i'm going to be the perfect person
everything goes through hr yeah i don't
have time to interview people dude like
what if it's someone you know
i mean if
a buddy comes to you hey you know i
wanna i'll be your assistant well if i
already know them i'll be like yeah or
no you know yeah i know whether i want
them or not um
so yeah i mean no everything goes
through hr and she goes through a
rigorous process of
you know having them send their resume
they've got to do personality tests um
how do you do that personally do you
have them do like a like a quiz online
yeah are you serious
briggs yeah but um it's called
predictive index um i think it cost us
like
a grand a year so like once again parent
company expense it's like when you think
about these other expenses too
you know the tech the crm we've created
to be the same across all companies now
so like if somebody gets taxed from us
everyone can see like oh this is a tax
client and then you know you have them
fill out a survey saying like what else
are you interested in out of all these
things we offer and so then there's
other offers that we can make them but
you know with
the personality test and all these other
softwares and things we have to buy to
run the parent company
most companies can't buy it by
themselves as a single company it just
doesn't make sense financially but when
it's spread across all these companies
it makes a lot of sense you know so like
the personality test we do that we you
know obviously read the resume if
everything looks good on the personality
in the resume you know she'll hop on a
virtual interview whatever if that goes
good
you know in person and um she'll meet
either you know typically that that
person will meet the ceo of the company
that they're hiring for to see if
there's a good fit that way the ceo is
not wasting their time like you think
you think about this other companies who
have cos like they're hiring people
themselves they're creating the job
posting
they are um interviewing all these
people and that takes away from them
actually running the company and doing
things that make money and so
when you think about our competitive
advantage it's like dude our ceos don't
have to worry about any of this crap
like running ads training sales people
hiring all they have to focus on is just
the day-to-day operations of what they
have in front of them you know how do we
get more deals how do we get these
houses fixed up and how do we get these
apartments stabilized like they're super
focused on just like the product and
service itself instead of all the
organizational stuff
that most companies lack
wow
wow pretty awesome
yeah man that's incredible thank you
you've built out an amazing structure
for a business
yeah i think you're jack's idol at this
point
assistants all the people
how many assistants can i have
jack's like you're going to malibu for
five days that sounds lovely
very lovely
um
i really only have one other question i
know that you're building one of the
nicest homes las vegas has ever seen
and the finances on that house are
ridiculous can you walk us through the
process of building that home and some
some of the numbers on it
so um
you know i bought this
you know what i'm calling a mountain it
was two acres um
you know in mcdonald highlands which is
you know one of the top areas here in
vegas i think
last year they had the highest sales
like 25 million dollars
for a house that sold in there and the
year before we actually sold the most
expensive house in there for 11 million
wow um
so yeah i found this lot that was just
such a great deal i bought it for 620
grand for two
it's an entire thing um
i don't know what it's worth today i
mean if i had to ballpark it could be
anywhere from five to ten million
um just because
you know lots in mcdonald highlands
right now with strip views are selling
at like four million dollars an acre
so
yeah whatever i'm not looking to sell it
but uh you know i bought a million
dollars right now
a million right now no i'm all right you
almost double your money i know i know
almost almost
we'll roll it into this yeah
so um you know i bought this land and i
immediately hired an architect and got
to work and so you know we spent about
man at least like seven eight months
doing this plan and all of a sudden like
my architect starts to have
family problems and i'll just kind of
leave it at that and um he wasn't able
to complete him
and so
you know we had to let him go and
find a new architect right but the
problem is on something like that a new
architect doesn't want to take the old
plans like they want to do their own
deal
and so we pretty much had the whole
decision of like
well we just pretty much wasted a year
we have to start over
and so
yeah i ended up um
it actually worked great because the new
guy um is amazing he's actually one of
my students he does developments in
beverly hills and stuff like sick homes
um i did a youtube video with him too
like he's doing 100 million dollar
development in l.a right now or beverly
hills and
um he was like first time i ever met him
he just joined the mastermind he was
like hey you know i saw your house
you know i'll do it for free
and i was like dude that's such a nice
offer but i don't know you like you're
you're my student right like you're not
doing that much i didn't know anything
about him and we already had our
architect well
you know as i got to know this guy more
his name's armor he uh you know i start
learning what he's doing i'm like holy
crap like the houses you're building are
insane and you asked about development
earlier a lot of our students have
actually partnered with him on
development you know across the country
like he's building sick houses so
you know long story short um
i go back to him and i'm like hey like
let's do this he's done you know we'll
build this and so
we hired him um
i don't know late last year january or
something and so um he's already
finished his renderings of this new
house which we haven't revealed and um
we had to
we had to tame it down because it was so
big and crazy
i was like bomber how big is this like
what what are we talking about here and
he's like it's you know looking at it
from the basketball court in the house
it's thirty thousand square foot oh come
on i know this guy this guy's like
building his dream house online and just
like well we need a room come on man
yeah so oh
well did you not give him any like man
tell him like not anything over 15 000
no no no so um
yeah obviously we give him the uh you
know like hey you know we're thinking
like
12 000 square feet for this type of home
is pretty much like right you know and i
also wanted like a basketball court and
a gym and stuff too outside of the house
and so um
you know he he built his thing so really
like his was like twenty thousand house
ten thousand like ugly recreational
right stuff and um
yeah i'm like dude this is just like i
don't even need this this is like crazy
and
you know he's basically like well you
know in the end
you can always downsize but you can't
upsize like once it's done so like my
job is to show you
like the full potential of what it could
be
and then you know you take out what you
don't want right and what's not
necessary and so yeah we're getting
those revisions back now where it's like
yeah you know this is tight this is
super sick don't get me wrong but we
just
don't need it sounds like you're using
uh the same guy who built nile miami's
house yeah who's that i don't know oh
the guy's the one
you could always build more you can't
you can't build more or you can build it
i'm losing it
i don't have something like that
something like that i don't know yeah so
anyways i don't always downsize that's
it you could always downsize right so
yeah i don't know um what it's gonna be
i mean dude i mean when i started this
back in the end of 2020 you know
labor material everything was so much
cheaper than it is today and so like the
cost of building has just skyrocketed in
the last year and a half since buying
the land so
i don't know what it's gonna end up
being um
i mean if i had to guess
it could be a
you know seven to ten million dollar
home just depending on what it is like
cost wise which
is crazy considering the land itself you
know would be a five to ten million
dollar piece of land on its own and then
you would build the house so if we were
all into the house for say
you know just even call it 10 million
dollars like
that house is worth 25 30 million
dollars because it's better than the
house that's over 25 like way better
and um you know so i don't know who
knows i might flip it by then i don't
know
would you okay so if you
built this incredible home would that be
your forever home or do you think you'd
move on to something else i'll wholesale
it
you could do a fund
let's find it out i'm gonna nft the home
and you know turn it into an airbnb yeah
yeah um
dude i don't know man i'm i'm so like
always open to anything and everything
that i don't ever like this is it my
life's done at this point like i don't
know dude um
i was telling you about the the modular
home that i bought recently right that
is where i'm gonna go live now because i
i wasn't looking i was gonna build this
house but then this flip just came up
and i'm like oh this house is sick like
it's 6 000 square feet it's you know on
a half an acre it's in a super nice
community you know i'm a golf member at
this community and so i'm like dude this
would be great i freaking golf cart to
the course like it's going to be epic
and so i just bought the house and i'm
like i'm just going to keep it instead
of flipping it and um the house is way
over budget now because i'm keeping it
but uh
i don't know like i'm kind of also at
the point now where
that house is so nice and like it's
totally fine like i don't need anything
more than that you know
but i also own this prime piece of real
estate that's like already being
developed and so there there could be a
chance that i just go flip this thing
and like build it out or even like
another exit strategist sell it with
these plans to somebody and like look
you know you got these
legit plans you've got this house and
you know 10 mil for everything and you
go build it yourself and you know
whatever you want to do so i don't know
but uh i'm not too worried about that
anymore as far as like
getting it done and moving in because
i'm moving into this and i'm like really
excited about this final question what
is your net worth and you can't like
count the
estimation of value of your businesses i
don't even know dude um if i had to
guess
it's probably close to 20 mil
as far as like real estate and um you
know cash and just like those types of
things but i mean honestly the real
value is in my businesses you know like
i i wouldn't sell my businesses for 20
million you know like
they make way more cash than that and i
know how hard it was to build up
those businesses to where they are today
and they're only going to keep getting
bigger and better you know so like
um that was something actually i
listening to hormozy talk about a lot
was really um
interesting it's like man
i mean it's true the wealthiest people
get wealthy from owning businesses it's
not from like buying real estate buying
real estate's great for like normal
everyday people but you know the true
wealth is made in owning these
businesses and then you know seeing like
what these rich guys do they just borrow
against their business value and they
never pay tax and they just
buy stuff that way and it's just like
yeah that's the way to go but it's also
by not buying starbucks and avocado
toast that helps that's true that's not
forgiving it starts there
and then it builds eventually to 20
million dollars every time in the long
run in the london run no and look i mean
that stuff will work like anyone can
become a millionaire today just being
frugal and buying real estate like
you'll get there
um
but like
the businesses are what my focus is on
like i would rather go dump
a million dollars into my business and
like it's technically not in my net
worth anymore because it's now
you know stuff that we've done for the
business maybe we're building out
software technology like we've spent a
lot of money developing software it's
like yeah obviously that doesn't it's
not on my network sheet the software we
spent all this money on but
it's making the business more valuable
and in the years to come it's going to
allow us to
you know make a lot more money so i
don't even care honestly like what my
net worth is like i've i have more money
than i ever thought i would and
um
i'm really passionate just about
building businesses and helping people
grow businesses and partnering up with
people like graham and like
you know just new opportunities and like
it's fun
doing this stuff
so i enjoy that
well perfect well ryan thank you so much
i really appreciate it we'll link to all
the information down below in the
description and creator properties is
probably gonna fill up fast so you
better act now before it's before it
fills up
so anyway uh oh oh also make sure to hit
the like button subscribe subscribe
mentorship group linked down below
get your free stock in public publicly
guys go ahead and follow me add me on
instagram
instagram go ahead thank you ryan so
much for coming on it's great seeing you
as per usual and
until next time until next time next
time thanks for having me guys you got
it
cool that was awesome